[Música]
el ministerio de economía y
planificación de cuba aprobó las
primeras 32 pequeñas y medianas empresas
privadas en más de medio siglo de
socialismo y gestión estatal la
aprobación da así luz verde a los
empresarios para proceder a su
constitución como personas jurídicas
para así ejercer actividades económicas
la medida rompe con décadas de gestión
estatal total de la actividad económica
en la década de los 60 en plena batalla
política entre washington y la habana
con la revolución de fidel castro
nacionalizó las empresas privadas estas
empresas deberán ceñirse a varias
limitaciones tendrán un máximo de 100
empleados además las actividades de
importación y exportación pasarán por el
gobierno y no se podrán crear empresas
en los sectores reservados sólo para el
control estatal como lo son las
telecomunicaciones el turismo y la salud
por ello les quiero dar la bienvenida a
nuestro segundo invitado el es jorge
duany ai director del instituto de
investigaciones cubanas de la
universidad internacional de la florida
profesor en antropología en el
departamento de estudios globales y
socioculturales de la misma universidad
el doctor jorge el profesor jorge por
estar aquí con nosotros en francés 24 en
directo le preguntó las implicaciones
que trae las empresas privadas a la
economía de la lista es una apertura
real
bueno la mayoría de los economistas
cubanos y en el exterior le han dado la
bienvenida a esta nueva legislación en
cuba' que permite precisamente
establecer empresas privadas y también
mixtas en la isla sin embargo el
consenso me parece que es que es una
reforma insuficiente puesto que todavía
restringe grandemente las oportunidades
de desarrollo empresarial por ejemplo no
permite que los cubanos residentes del
estado en el exterior establezcan esas
empresas y también establece unas tasas
impositivas demasiado altas para el
desarrollo de estas nuevos negocios
el doctor hablando de estos o nuevos
negocios o como se prevé en que
funcionen en la isla cómo pueden
funcionar estas empresas privadas o
mixtas con el estado es muy difícil
constituir una empresa privada en cuba
es muy difícil las restricciones
burocráticas todo el proceso de permisos
para empezar o para formalizar una
empresa ya existente es muy complicado
y los empresarios ya se han comenzado a
quejar de que precisamente ese ambiente
tan burocrático tan un limitante le va a
ser muy difícil establecer las empresas
y la otra cuestión que también ya se ha
señalado es que hasta ahora de esas
treinta y pico de nuevas empresas
realmente se trata principalmente de
empresas ya existentes lo que en cuba se
conoce como el trabajo por cuenta propia
que no es otra cosa que pequeñas
iniciativas privadas que no habían sido
reconocidas hasta ahora en la
legislación osea hablamos entonces de
empresas de emprendedores que tenían
mucho tiempo ya funcionando la isla que
simplemente se formalizaron ante el
gobierno eso es lo que eso es lo que le
entiendo y también quería hablar y dijo
que solamente pueden hacerlo las
personas que están en la isla es decir
alguien con capital extranjero no puede
invertir en una empresa ya constituida
dentro de cuba para poder funcionar
digamos porque también entiendo que hay
muchas empresas que necesitan esta
inyección económica para poder
constituirse y puede funcionar con toda
la legalidad en cuba' correcto y hasta
ahora ese fenómeno se estaba dando de
manera informal sobre todo con la gran
cantidad de miles de millones de dólares
que los cubanoamericanos y otros cubanos
residente del exterior le enviaban a sus
parientes en cuba pero ese dinero no
aparecía oficialmente como inversión
extranjera y tampoco la nueva generación
reconoció oficialmente el dinero yo
supongo que continuará llegando esa
injerencia de fondos pero desde el punto
de vista legal los propietarios tienen
que ser personas que residan como ahora
es de este modelo nuevo modelo económico
quien se va a beneficiar más el estado o
los emprendedores o si va a hacer algo
algo mutuo digamos que se beneficia en
ambos sectores
no hay duda de que el estado cubano está
buscando alternativas para mejorar
el ritmo de desarrollo económico que
sobre todo durante la pandemia se redujo
sustancialmente y ya hay algunos
economistas que han estimado que
posiblemente la tasa de crecimiento del
producto interno bruto crecería entre un
2% lo cual no es despreciable para una
economía en recesión como como la cubana
pero si uno lee entrelíneas
ese documento recién aprobado por
el gobierno cubano se da cuenta de que
la mayor parte los beneficios sobre todo
a través de los impuestos y también de
las ventas y el monopolio del comercio
exterior va a ser directamente con el
estado aparte de eso hay que también
tomar en cuenta que en cuba' hoy en día
se está dólar y polarizando la economía
a partir de enero de este año y que por
lo tanto al ciudadano común y corriente
que suele ganar su salario en pesos
cubanos se le hace muy difícil cumplir
con las expectativas de comprar y vender
sus productos en dólares
ahora profesor vemos que hay en digamos
una apertura del modelo económico y que
es un poco diferente al modelo político
que tiene pues la dinastía castro ahora
en cabeza del presidente miguel díaz
canel qué tan sostenible es esto además
también le quiero preguntar si esto pues
es un bálsamo digamos o para los cubanos
con las protestas que vimos semanas
atrás es donde rechazaban completamente
pues el gobierno socialista de la isla
del sistema económico como reciben los
cubanos que viven en en la isla pues
está esta especie de apertura económica
sí bueno no hay duda de que
efectivamente las protestas callejeras
que ocurrieron el 11 de julio han
incidido de alguna manera en la
autorización de estas reformas hay que
decir también que las reformas ya habían
sido aprobadas inicialmente hace una
década cuando el gobierno de raúl castro
había comenzado una serie de tímidas
reformas autorizando el trabajo por
cuenta propia y una apertura al capital
extranjero pero esas reformas se fueron
frenando sobre todo durante la época de
administración trump
y el cierre de las fronteras con el
exterior de cuba entonces tal parece que
la la aprobación final de estas reformas
fue producto en parte de esa presión
desde abajo es muy difícil todavía saber
cuál es la reacción de los cubanos de a
pie pero indudablemente tanto del sector
de cuentapropistas y de los futuros
empresarios privados ha habido un
entusiasmo con estas reformas pero como
decía al principio también ha habido
cierto cierto escepticismo sobre las
restricciones que va a existir pero por
lo menos aunque es un cambio y un cambio
positivo en la dirección correcta
acercaría esto al gobierno de miguel
díaz canel a la actual administración
del presidente estadounidense iovine
el propio díaz canel celebro esta
reforma como la llamada actualización
del modelo económico cubano que como
dije en su momento se viene dando de
hace algún tiempo por parte del partido
comunista que no es otra cosa que tratar
de abrir la economía lo suficiente pero
manteniendo un férreo control de las
expresiones políticas hasta ahora el
gobierno de bailén no ha reaccionado a
estas iniciativas más bien ha
expresado su descontento con la manera
en que se manejó por parte del gobierno
cubano las protestas del 11 de julio y
ha habido incluso un reconocimiento del
embargo que había ya comenzado durante
la publicación trump pero hasta ahora no
tenemos indicios de cuál va a ser la
nueva política si es que va a ser nueva
de la administración vaya profesor dwan
y ya por último cuál es el futuro
económico a su parecer de la isla hacia
dónde va
bueno la tendencia ha sido hacia una
creciente mezcla del sector estatal
cubano que sigue siendo el dominante
pero una expansión de el llamado sector
no estatal que en otros países conoce
como empresa privada ya alrededor de de
un 13% de los trabajadores cubanos son
trabajadores por cuenta propia y esa
tendencia parece ser
creciente a menos que el gobierno esté
hacia atrás algunas de esas reformas que
había autorizado en el pasado que está
autorizando ahora así que el futuro
probablemente será una economía mixta
pero con una apuesta por parte del
gobierno de seguir insistiendo las
empresas estatales socialistas